Richard Boyle says,
hi,
Dr. Peterson,
how does this score of 91 for compassion
and one for politeness equals a score
of 35 for agreeableness?
Yeah.
While it's because 91 and
one aren't ordinary numbers,
their percentiles and you
can't just average percentiles,
it doesn't work that way.
What it says is that
at sea,
I don't know if I can generate at just a
description on the fly because I'm not,
I wouldn't say I'm particularly
mathematically gifted,
although I know that the answer
I just gave you is correct.
Let's see,
there's a one in,
there's a one in 10 chance that a person
would be that compassionate and a one
and 100% chance that a
person would be that,
that,
that uh,
nope,
I can't generate it on the fly,
but that's the answer.
So if you want to point
to the proper literature,
you'd look up,
uh,
how to transform
percentiles into z scores.
They're called z scores,
then you can,
if you,
oh,
that's how it works.
You convert the percentiles
in disease scores,
you some the z scores and then you
reconvert them into percentiles.
And so if you take the z score for not
for compassion 91 and the z score for
politeness one,
add them,
divide them into and reconvert
them to a percentile,
you'll get 35 I know.
It's weird,
but that's,
that's how it,
that's how it is.
That's how it's done.